we've already talked about the process
from going from dna
to
messenger rna and we call that process
transcription and this occurs in the
nucleus
in the nucleus and then that messenger
rna makes it makes its way outside of
the nucleus and it attaches to a
ribosome and then it is translated
into a protein
it is translated into a protein and so
you could say that this is this part
right over here this is happening as
this is being facilitated by a ribosome
or it's happening at a ribosome
with that high level overview i now want
to think a little bit in more detail
about how this actually happens or the
structure of things where this happens
inside of a cell
and so i'm going to now draw the nucleus
in a little bit more detail so we can
really see what's happening on its
membrane so this right over here
this over here is the nucleus actually
let me draw it like this
and instead of just drawing it just
drawing the nucleus with one single line
i'm going to draw it with two lines
because it's actually a double
bi lipid
membrane
so this is one bi-lipid layer right over
here and then this is another one
right over here and i'm obviously not
drawing it to scale i'm drawing it so
that you can get a sense of things so
each of these lines that i'm drawing if
i were to zoom in on this so if i were
to zoom in on each of these lines so
let's zoom in
and if i got a box like that you would
see
you would see a bi-lipid layer so
a bi-lipid layer
looks like
this you have the circle is a
hydrophilic end and those lines are the
fatty hydrophobic ends so that's our
bi-lipid layer so that's each of these
each of these lines that i have drawn
each of them are a bilipid layer
so the question is well how does the
mrna obviously you have all this
transcription going on you have the dna
you have the mrna it's all
in here in this big jumble of chromatin
inside the nucleus how does it make its
way outside of this bilipid outside of
this double bi-lipid layer and the way
it makes it way out is through nuclear
pores
so a nuclear pore
a nuclear pore is essentially a tunnel
and there are thousands of these is a
tunnel
through this bi-lipid layer so and the
tunnel is made up of a bunch of proteins
so this right over here and this is kind
of a cross-section of it but you could
almost imagine it if you're thinking of
it in three dimensions you would imagine
a a tunnel a protein constructed a
tunnel made out of proteins that goes
through that goes through this this
double bilipid membrane
and so the mrna
so the mrna can make its way out the
mrna can make its way out and get to a
free ribosome and get to a free ribosome
and then be
translated into a protein and then be
translated into a protein
but this right over here is not the
complete picture because when you when
you translate a protein using a free
ribosome this is for proteins that are
used inside the cell so let me
draw the entire cell right over here so
this is entire this is the cell this
right over here is the cytosol of the
cell cytosol and you might be sometimes
confused with the term cytosol and
cytoplasm cytosol is all the fluid
between the organelles cytoplasm is
everything that's inside the cell so
it's the cytosol and the organelles and
the stuff inside the organelles is the
cytoplasm so cytoplasm is everything
inside of the cell cytosol is just the
fluid that's between the organelles
so anyway the free ribosome over here
this tr this translation is good for
proteins used within the cell itself
that the proteins can then float around
the cytosol and used in in whichever way
is appropriate but how do you get
protein outside of the cell or even
inside the cellular membrane not within
it within the cell but embedded in the
cell membrane or outside of the cell
itself and we know that cells
communicate in all sorts of different
ways and they produce proteins for other
cells or for use in the bloodstream or
whatever it might be and that's what
we're going to focus on in this video
so contiguous with this with this what's
called the paranuclear space right over
here so the space between these two
membranes so
you have this paranuclear space between
the inner and outer nuclear membrane let
me just label that that's the inner
nuclear membrane that's the outer
nuclear membrane
you could continue
you could continue this outer nuclear
membrane and you would and you get into
these kind of flaps and folds and bung
bulges
and this right over here is considered a
separate organelle so you get this thing
that looks like this and i'll just do it
the best that i can draw it and this
right over here is called the
endoplasmic reticulum
so this right here is endo
endoplasmic
reticulum which i've always thought
would be a good name for band and the
endoplasmic retic reticulum is key for
starting to produce and then later on
package proteins that are used for that
are either embedded in the cellular
membrane or used outside of the cell
itself so how does that happen
well the endoplasmic reticulum really
has two regions it has the rough
endoplasmic reticulum and the rough
endoplasmic re endoplasmic reticulum has
a bunch of ribosomes so that's a free
ribosome right over here this is an
attached ribosome this is a ribosome
these are ribosomes that are attached to
the membrane of the endoplasmic
reticulum so this region where you have
attached ribosomes right over here that
is the rough
that is the rough
endoplasmic reticulum i'll call it the
rough er for short perhaps an even
better name for a band and then there's
another region which is a smooth
endoplasmic reticulum
and the role that this plays in protein
synthesis or at least getting proteins
ready for the outside of the cell is you
can have messenger rna
messenger rna right let me do that in
that lighter green color
you can have messenger rna
find one of these ribosomes associated
with the rough endoplasmic reticulum and
as the protein is translated it won't be
translated inside the cytosol it'll be
translated on the other side of the
rough endoplasmic endoplasmic reticulum
or you could say on the inside of it on
the lumen of or in the lumen of the
rough endoplasmic the rough endoplasmic
reticulum let me make that a little bit
let me draw that a little bit better so
let's say that this right over here
that right over here is the membrane of
the endoplasmic reticulum and then as a
as a protein or as an mrna is being
translated into protein
the ribosome can attach
and at the let's say that this right
over here
this right over here is the mrna that is
being translated let's say it's being
it's going in that direction right over
here here is the membrane of the er
so er
membrane
er membrane
this right over here and actually the
way i've drawn it right over here this
is just one bi-lipid layer so let me
just i could draw it like this
i could do it like this
and this is actually this bilipid layer
is continuous it's continuous with the
outer nuclear membrane
so let me just make it
make it like
that so you get the picture and then at
some point of the in the trans in the
translation process the protein can be
spit out on the inside
on the inside as as it's being
translated it can be spit out on the
inside of the endoplasmic reticulum so
this is the lumen
this is the er lumen right over here so
we're inside the the endoplasmic
reticulum here here we're outside here
we're outside
outside in
the cytosol
in the saudis in the in the cytos
outside in the cytosol so that way you
get the protein now inside the er inside
the endoplasmic reticulum it can travel
through it and at some point it can butt
off so let's say imagine the protein is
right over here and the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum has many functions
and i won't get to all of the depth of
of what how it's
involved
but at some point that protein can bud
off and so let me draw a budding off
protein so let's say this is a
this is the the membrane of the
endoplasmic reticulum
and a protein
let's say ends up ends up
right over here and then it can butt out
so it could go from that
to
let me do that same color you can go
from that to
that
do that i think you see where this is
going
do that
and then
to
that and then it could go to something
like this
to something like this now it has butted
out and when you have a protein or
really you have anything that's being
transported around a cell with its own
little mini membrane we call this a
vesicle so now it'll bundle up and now
it is a vesicle
now this vesicle can then let me draw
let me draw some of these vesicles
holding some proteins
so let me draw that
can then go to the golgi apparatus
the golgi apparatus which i'll draw in
blue right over here as best as i can
so the golgi apparatus
this is not obviously there could be
better
drawings of something like this and then
they can essentially do the reverse
process and they can attach themselves
to the golgi oftentimes the golgi body
named after mr golgi who discovered this
and then the proteins once they get into
the the inside of the golgi body then
they essentially go into a
maturation process so that they're ready
for transport outside of the cell or
maybe to be embedded into the cellular
membrane so this right over here is the
golgi body or a golgi body or golgi
apparatus
golgi
or golgi body and then once they're done
with that with that process
then this is kind of the the fully
manufactured protein
ready to be used
ready to be used and actually yeah maybe
maybe i'll make it a slightly different
well i'll just use that same color this
is the fully manufactured protein and
now it can transport to the cell
membrane
and it can that protein can either be
transported outside of the cell or it
can be embedded within the membrane
itself